what's going on guys so we are deep into
summer movie season but still a lot to
look forward to Apes guardians turtles
everybody's talking about this Turtles
movie saying oh it's gonna be good it's
gonna be bad what are they gonna do to
our precious Turtles but people seem to
be forgetting that the turtles have done
some forgettable things in their past
there have been some interesting
questionable moments in turtle history
and we have an awesome panel to break
that down with first he is the
internet's black nerd our good friend
Andre Meadows bossanova and he produces
a ton of awesome content on red letter
media Jay balm and J good a via Chevy
Nova so guys let me ask you this what is
your ultimate version of the Turtles I
grew up with a cartoon the original
cartoon and the first season of that I
remember it being great the animation
was good it had a nice story and I think
it was the second season where
everything started to look cheaper there
were moments where they animated the
wrong color on the mask oh boy the color
the mask is like how you tell them apart
you have the wrong voice coming out of
the wrong man going on yeah whoa judge
its those turtle wrestlers there are
precious moments in turtle dumb but
there I have a few things here that yeah
our head scratchers I didn't realize the
turtles were big into Christmas I'm
gonna get four splinter gotta get it yet
gotta gotta get okay how'd it get
against gotta get it again
well actually is not just that song it's
a full videotape of turtle Christmas
songs on the first day of Christmas the
total dick to me a piece of baloney
another great thing one of the turtles
takes the piece of pizza puts it in his
mouth and then takes it out because he
can't anything another turtle Matt it's
just like like he forgot he's like oh
yeah Wow
thanks leo I was gonna buy one myself
like I told did you'd like it and this
was a spin-off of another video turtle
tracks which is a spin-off of the major
thing that started all this music stuff
which is the coming out of shells tour
talk to me a little bit about the coming
out of their shells tour someone said
how do we make money with turtles and
moving more money more money with Ninja
Turtles let's have him start a fan so
they had the coming out of the shells
tour which was this was a big thing like
not only to have a tour but they also
had cassette tapes that you could get
from my Pizza Hut then just in a tour
video yeah that's what I remember the
most and that was I remember seeing that
that was the moment where I realized
that maybe I was becoming an adult it's
like I don't have time for this the solo
by splinter oh yes
skipping stones Oh skipping stones
cuz you know that's what kids want from
what Ninja Turtle show a smooth soft
ballad from splitter around the time of
the tour they were making different
appearances and they sat down with
Barbara Walters hello Barbara
and they also sat down with Oprah
Barbara scooped Oprah Barbara got the
good turtles Oprah got like the janky
turtles you know why are you wet dick
the reason for the tour was that the
turtles decided to put down their
weapons and instead they picked up
instruments we talked a little bit about
the positive messages they don't want
you to go out and hit anyone in the face
with a bo staff they did this PSA where
I'm sorry it looks like they took just
existing footage of Ninja Turtle
cartoons yeah that's what they did does
it get just dubbed whatever they wanted
Joey's in a gym what'd she do okay
excellent get a pizza can real this so
cheapest way to do a PSA yeah like they
you know they ran a red light or
something this is all right you don't
really have to show up like you know
what pili Herman did that thing about
crack like how would it feel if they
just took Clips a pee-wee's Playhouse
and just had him go back what is like
cherry and play around I don't think
I've seen this ho this is crack rock
cocaine and what I love after that is
that I guess Michelangelo just decided
to go on a crusade cuz he joined a bunch
of other cartoon characters uh-huh for
this special called cartoon all-stars to
the rescue and it was like him the
Smurfs and the Chipmunks Muppet Babies
but it was just Michelangelo I can only
afford one turtle yeah it's come to
think of it that's a lot of your problem
what problem drugs bud your brain must
be like really messed up another
incarnation was the next mutation they
introduced the female and her shell had
boobs sorry
sort of one stronger than I expected I
don't understand why a female turtle
would need my a turtle would need boobs
yeah do turtles give milk now though
nipples tell us the turtles give milk
dude can you drink a nice glass at
turtle milk let us know okay oh boy yeah
the next mutation that was made from the
same people who made Power Rangers yes
oh of course
for advertising purposes you had a
crossover episode where the Ninja
Turtles met the Power Rangers alone like
bar
things I can't believe it but I think
there it's the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles some would call this a low
moment so we call this a high point in
turtle history vanilla ice can it be
both yeah it's kind of both that might
be the first the ninja rap might be the
first thing I ever loved ironically I
love vanilla ice performing the turtles
however I can see like a businessman in
the back with a large cigar going these
Turtles we can just put them on anything
yeah I think that's what led to like
what happened here like what is yeah the
turtles were his favorite color yeah
it's pretty sad yeah but uh a great
moment from our youth yeah yeah so what
is your favorite turtle memory what's
your least favorite turtle memory leave
us an answer in the comments section
below
coolest answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
these two awesome dudes for coming to
our little pizza party today Andre
Meadows black nerd comedy and Jay
Baumann red letter media checking both
out subscribe also I want to take a
moment to thank a viewer of screen
junkies and an all-around awesome dude
Matt Dorado sent us a number of original
art pieces that he created we've got him
hanging around the set we're hanging him
in the office matt has an Etsy store
where you can purchase his original
creations check out the link in the
description below worth checking out
quality stuff Matt thank you brother and
I want to thank you for watching the
show I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter hit these guys up on Twitter bye
bye this is my prediction for Harrison
Ford II the reason you need to shut the
movie down before you even write a three
I mean what the hell is Harrison Ford
gonna do in the movie no I'll tell you
whatever supports you to do in this
movie he's gonna show up in the
helicopter say I got a bad feeling about
this
and then just take off